very fortunate and i mean yeah this move
after queen c5 i think this was one of
the first moments when i had just a
couple of seconds
um left to make my move when i played
king h7 which i think
practically speaking you know not a bad
move um the idea was
if she plays queen f8 here then i have
rook to a8 and spending the position
right and everything and look there's
this cool line this this deflection
doesn't work
right we did point this out in the
broadcast after the queen takes you
can't take that yeah that d
pawn is in the way well really a
tremendous fight
um and your main rival anna zatonski won
her game
right so now for the first time since
it's been zero zero actually
you guys are now tied for first uh
deja vu actually uh we were tied first i
think after three rounds because we had
two
both had two and a half so now we're
tied again
um so it's not not that unusual of a
situation yeah i mean i expected anna to
win
um so the fact that we're tied that's
kind of a normal occurrence
you know we've still got four games and
i still still my game with anna coming
up
so yeah so there's a lot to look forward
to and
i definitely feel rather fortunate that
i saved this game
um i mean i blundered for example this
move rook e7
um that was a you know i don't know what
was going on here but i of course
completely i missed this move and um
there were a lot of things
that i could have missed in this game
and just lost right away and i'm not
very good with uh three seconds on my
clock
why do you get in time pressure all the
time is that that increment is so
enticing
when you get a out time frame
games maurice that i i mean yesterday
one was like you know 40 minutes on my
clock but
i haven't been in any time pressure in
these games um really
only um this is my first game and it was
just kind of a tough game
you know it's pretty balanced and um i
mean it was the first game
where i wasn't um where we know we had a
real fight you know both ways
um but yeah i feel fortunate that i
didn't blunder
and didn't have to suffer much to make a
draw in the rook end game either because
yeah it was pretty easy
to make a draw and uh it's nice not to
have to suffer
well good for you and we wish you the
best in the rest of your games good luck
in the rest of the champions thank you
maurice
grandmaster arena crush after surviving
a barn burner
she has four strong rounds to go but
she's still tied for first
back to you guys great game just great
game good
very exciting yeah all three results are
possible
a mix of tactics strategic play
and games and also even opening
um both players trying to outfox one
another in the opening
as well so that game had content as we
would say
that's right and now we've got uh
people suffering so i really said she
was glad she didn't have to suffer much
but
as we pointed out ramirez is suffering
against a koban
and uh probably going to suffer his way
to a loss right
that's he didn't like his chances to
hold on here that was
my thinking as well but he
he didn't i'm a little surprised
that var didn't go for that position
with a trade of rooks
i thought that getting the rooks to d8
and bishop to c5
that would have been a very fine
and clear continuation
for white uh he's put his rook on g2
uh when his rook when when his rook is
on d2 and this rook is on d6 this knight
is basically
frozen so the one thing that uh
well ramirez is his dreaming is that he
will be able to one day bring his knight
to e5
so the one thing that var should
definitely not allow
is for that on the other hand var might
be thinking that with his rook on
g2 he could play for h4 h5
trying to undermine this pawn on f6 that
looks a little fanciful
to me and i do see moves are being
var tickled the bishop on c4 with work
d4 and ramirez instantly played bishop
b3
because it was forced okay if you played
a bishop to b5 bishop a2 check would be
fatal extremely nasty which is supposed
to show the power of those two bishops
right
well let me just show that to our
audience a bishop b5 would be a
very unfortunate uh embarrassment
to the king nothing to be done here
except to resign
and now i'm just wondering is the bishop
running out of squares though jen
can't uh var con continue to harass the
bishop
where is that bishop going to go that's
a good question because the bishop a for
bishop a true check is exactly the same
variation precisely so
oh my nap just looks
instantly instantly winning
wow all right well maybe we'll see this
one uh um
well actually this did happen and
ramirez has played g5 g5
check so check is good the idea is
now that if the king were just to slide
away
bishop a4 and now bishop a2 check
oh king g7 at least
so the move g7 g5 has has given
black's king up a square we're not
saying we like it for black
no no no no nobody likes it for boys
we're just saying maybe not immediate
resignation but
we'll take a look and see we've got ana
zatonski
winning and now tied for the lead with
irina crush
she is with maurice accolade
indeed with four-time champion anna
zatonski
first of all welcome to the show yeah
thank you you had a
pretty dominant win in this game were
you surprised by the way she played the
opening trading off all the pieces on f6
and not getting much out of the the y
pieces yes so i was surprised and i
think
she didn't know this opening and bishop
e7 was probably
your move for her really did she did she
expect you to play the french at all or
i think she expects me to play french
but even uh playing french i'm
i can i could play like so many
variations i played bishop e7 last time
uh if i'm not mistaken 12 years ago and
i'm playing
so many other different i i think it
just uh
she didn't expect this bishop is seven
and i would like to thank my husband
danielle friedman for recommending me
this line yeah
it worked out very well yeah it's nice
to have a grandmaster for her husband
at least sometimes indeed you got
a great position on the o but it looked
like she might have had some fighting
chances but
but she just lost a pawn and got a bad
position when you took on g2
i think it's the moment she didn't see
bishop due to probably
because she could sacrifice upon in my
better version
with some compensation she could play
i think she couldn't defend upon already
after queen h4 but
could you have better position with more
chances
indeed so now you're tied for first yeah
with your main rival irina crush you
guys don't play until much later in the
tournament
how does it feel to be right here you
guys have been here
it feels like eight or nine times
already uh okay so
nothing yours more or less the same and
i will try to concentrate on future
games like
you saw we can make before our game we
will lose some points like i already
mentioned in my interview
and i i will just concentrate on the
game against camilla tomorrow even
if she's not in very good shape she's
still very strong
chess player so i'm concentrating on the
game tomorrow and then
in three days i will think about irenas
and by the way i would like to
give credit to carmilla that i think
she's so
uh she uh her title is
highest in this tournament she was a
junior world champion under 20.
so i know we were u.s champions but
still with
this title it's sure very valuable
yeah world champion uh titles yes quite
a bit
so what do you think about your game
tomorrow what's your record against her
yes so
i don't know i will prepare and i will
take it as seriously as i can
and your record against her do you know
know
we did quite a few draws i think and i
don't remember if i lost any game so but
uh we we did quite to draw some
you know i think in 2009
i drew her the only one drawing and she
took second place
i took first and she took second night
just going back to a second to this
great rivalry because it really has been
something for the books this is this era
in in u.s women's chess
will will be remembered as the the anna
and arena error i mean she's got five
you've got four
do you come in with with some feeling
like maybe you'd like to at least get
your fifth one as well
yeah of course i will try my best of
course you know
yeah it it it's very important for me
also to take first place and
i will try my best i will try to prepare
to be in good shape to
be very motivated i think it's also very
important
because i'm not 18 anymore so i need to
be very motivated to play good chess and
i suspect your husband will be helping
you some more as well
yes of course yeah how do you guys
communicate phone or skype
uh it's either skype or phone yeah
mostly skype
and yeah sometimes i disagree with him
because i'm not feeling like i'm gonna
play this and and we're talking and of
course like
like i said before uh he never
encouraged me to play first move e4 and
as you can
as you could see i played g4 and beat
tatia very important
game we had a big conversation before
the game yeah
but this time you did listen to him and
it worked out yes
but sometimes sometimes
i don't listen human it's not very good
well thanks so much and good win and we
wish you the best in the rest of this
world
thank you thank you anna zatonski
doing her thing which is not nothing new
to her
and she's tied for first with arena
crush back to you guys
personally i think daniel just got lucky
on this one i mean he just
chose the right right defense and gave
uh on a good idea and it worked out
brilliantly
normally it doesn't when i try to try to
mix
opening ideas for my wife yvette
normally they rebounded
why did i make such a suggestion so uh
jesus woman tends to be right i'll be no
certainly right of course she's
certainly right so g5
check and now yeah you might have been
caught
by surprised by this move but certainly
he doesn't want to take
on bason here because that will allow
the knight out of his cage and it seems
like they're
well that position probably isn't bad
for white either there's got to be way
better options
right you you know that night has been
passive the whole game so allowing it to
enter the fray with a check that's
really
not nice so instead he might be thinking
about which square would he prefer
the king to go on f3 or g4
the reason i'm picking g4 and it may
well turn out that
f3 is the proper square is i just wanted
to keep contact with the
bishop and to
keep that extra tempo going so i was
thinking that you would have
a situation like bishop a4
and now whether i should play rook d6 or
not i'm
i was looking at a line that went rook d
six as in give me the pawn
i'm aware that there's a set an exchange
sacrifice by the way that i haven't
figured out the ramifications of um
but in case of knight d7 one idea
option i thought i would have is that i
could bring this bishop to the e6 square
and that's probably why black in fact
should sacrifice the exchange and this
exchange sacrifice might be
just fine in fact so a tough decision
actually for a var and um a key moment
here after
the move g5 only move only move
because everything else was just uh
terrible
so again the exchange sacrifice
probably is enough compensation
um just because i don't really have a
very good
well how is it you want to get self-made
yeah exactly
i was good let's go in there not king
h5 that would be a mistake
um check me um king h3 but i'm
ah this is weird jen i'm not sure here
because i'm a little bit worried that
this king
after some moves like check could find
itself
well again it's still it's not that bad
this hmm
well at some point i have to play knight
d7 just to protect my pawn
right and um it might be enough for a
draw
it might be enough for a draw but white
definitely on top here
yeah uh
idea here by ramirez to keep things a
little bit complicated
and we've got a we've got to move first
of all it seems that he's played
none of the moves that we considered he
didn't pikachu kenji for
working after he played king e3 oh
really okay
and we've got uh maurice ashley for his
thoughts on this game
well looking at it with houdini it looks
as though
varacobian missed a very powerful
continuation
yes in your line after king to g4
this move bishop to a4 you were
wondering
how can you start the attack on this
pawn well the key is
to get the king out of there and guess
where you need to go
into the heart of the position with the
move king to h5
this move would have cemented the
advantage
more so than the other line why because
if
black tries to defend with this move
rook to d7
white can now break open the position
with this move h4
and suddenly white has all kinds of
possibilities with his rook
having effect his bishop opening up on
this diagonal
the pawn structure about to crack for
black so this is the line
that houdini liked it's not totally over
obviously
but still very nice for white to see the
game opening up
with those two bishops on the board
black could have been in serious trouble
here
but ocobian played a different move here
he played the move
king let's see after g5 he played the
move
king to e3 which does give him still
a bit of an advantage but his advantage
has dipped from over one now
to only 0.66 that means about a little
bit more than half upon
which in layman's terms basically means
he has a bit of an edge
but not as much and as significant than
he had in the other line
back to you guys so the move king
f4 to e3 dropped half upon
how did i lose half a pound i mean i
understand losing a pawn
but i lost half upon witnessing you
don't expect the players to follow all
the computer lines
no some of them are counter-intuitive
and uh
well it's interesting that uh
the ramirez was able to get in the shot
g5 check at just a moment
that he really really needed it because
i was thinking at some moment that white
var could have probably played h4
on a number of occasions not necessarily
with the idea of h5 and h6 but simply
h4 with the idea of just keeping that g7
pawn
firmly cemented and uh
after king e3 by the way that that
is a nice point isn't it um about the
move g5
uh what what uh maurice was saying here
just as well yeah it's very lovely
i mean the the king the king gets
uh in a kind of a pocket it looks a
little bit
uh funny at first you know
you might be worried that you're after
say king g7
they'll be something like rook takes e4
and a bishop e8 mate right so
and you intuitively don't want to
stick your uh that's what i meant by
yeah
you're king in the news yeah it's not
easy always to play the computer
recommendations because
they don't take it to take into
consideration that feeling that like if
you could
drop a rook at h4 it would be game over
28
right exactly and those instincts that
we develop are usually for good reason
but of course they're just instincts and
principles right
that work the vast majority of the time
but when when
those rare occasions that our instincts
are wrong it can cost us half a point
exactly and we've got some news on the
bahan sky team melakina game will
camilla win her first game of the
tournament as her friend anna satonski
pointed out
former world girls under 20 champ
well it doesn't look like it in this
game because she has allowed
the advantage to slip and it looks as
though she's the one who's trying to
defend
and maybe make a draw in this game look
what happened here
she had been up a pawn for quite some
time it was a
benko gambit from the opening and so she
had tried to
solidify this a pawn has been sitting
there forever
and in this moment she decides on the
maneuver knight to a3 she didn't like
her night
being wayward in this position but it
turns out to be the wrong idea
because of this move queen f3
posting the queen in a very powerful
position definitely preventing this
queen from ever leaving
going anywhere and you have to be
careful here moves like rook to d3 for
example
could be met by the move bishop to e3
out of nowhere suddenly black is
completely winning
in this game obviously you cannot take
the bishop because of queen to f1 check
king up and then the rook down bang and
that's going to be game
over so queen to f3 preventing any
trades
the same move would happen if queen to
ether well actually you can't even move
this because the f pawn is hanging
so all those lines are bad after queen
f3 she brought her knight back over like
she thought she would and then suddenly
this move rook to e8
and now this rook ready to post in on
the e2 square
and white is looking at the board
thinking
what did i do because now the position
is very different
again this time the rook to d3
absolutely doesn't work
because of a simple mate in two king up
and either piece to h1 would be
checkmate
so she had to grovel with rook to f1
and black c and black sees their chance
with the move rook to e2
and you know black is thinking how did
this happen after all this suddenly
i'm back in the game and now the move d3
and black is happy here
white played the move knight to e5
trying to chase the queen out of there
queen dropped back to f5 and now knight
to g4
and bishop to g7 was played
i should point out after knight to after
queen to f5
knight takes pawn is not possible
because of rook to d2 thank you very
much
so black with all the initiative now in
the current position
after bishop to g7 she's trying to get
her pieces to come around a bishop could
land on a d4 square
no reason to be afraid now with the
black pieces so it looks like white has
frittered away her advantage
and she's going to have to struggle to
just even save this position
here in the women's championships back
to you guys
thank you maurice that queen f5 move by
the way because i was looking at knight
takes d3
uh rook d2 but that queen f5 move uh
was better than the queen e4 move that
we had looked at
see and then the difference is also that
after queen a one check bishop g7
right switch back to g7 and all is
lovely
exactly and uh we do have one more game
that we haven't looked at in a while for
del greyev
we've got some results coming in the u.s
women's championship foyzer zenyuk was a
draw
knee nemkova was also a draw so
less blood spilled than usual in the
women's championship but of course that
abrahamian crush game did not disappoint
as rita pointed out it was really the
first game
where it wasn't one-sided and that
you know she was really she really had
some troubles
she was in fear of losing the game
absolutely she had another draw
in the tournament versus zenyuk but she
wasn't
fearing death right all three results
were possible in this in her game today
and yes she
well she doesn't get down to like so
it's just a
handful of seconds on the clock unless
her opponent's putting great pressure on
her
so it was a it was a wonderful fight
great battle
and oh sorry yes
um luther reasonably balanced remember
we saw that graham had the two bishops
but fergal
seemed to have this potential outpost on
c5 and
a nicer pawn structure to play against
right
so we have this position when we left
it's something about these parts
and it looks like josh is just doing
fine
and the bishop would otherwise get
trapped i believe if we took
and this bishops of opposite color
are endings that so often are drawn it
just
really looks like the game is heading
towards a draw at this point
which is a an important result for our
tournament leaders of course
yes because now graham can't catch not
turbine and lenderman could be in the
lead and lassicobian
wins his game against ramirez so if kobe
wins against ramirez will have
a tie for the lead between okobian and
lender man like in the women's section
there's
two co-leaders that's right
yes we've got uh maurice for some
thoughts on
that crucial game which we're going to
keep a close eye on okobe and ramirez
well the most significant thing about
that game right now is the clock
they're in a sudden death time control
with 30 second increments
but look at the clocks 209 for
ocobian the game is still full of fight
he's definitely better in this position
houdini is even saying that he's way up
the way this sequence has gone
he's got a great bishop along this
diagonal hitting this pawn
this knight has to sit here to control
this
f6 square also the bishop a2 check could
come in at any time
also h4 could come in any time so a very
pleasant position indeed
for ocobian but ramirez has 21 minutes
left
on his clock tons of time to try to put
up a sturdy defense
and how do you play perfect poised chess
right at this moment when you only have
two minutes left even with those 30
second increments
it's going to be extremely hard to play
accurate moves so what all ramirez is
going to want to do
is just keep it solid keep it solid for
as long as possible
because if he does not only might he
make it a draw
he might even turn the game around on a
mistake by a cobian so we'll take
a long look at that clock keep a
watchful eye because
it's going to be a big part of the
finish of this game
back to you guys that's right so
kubein ramirez crucial for today's
standings
we've got some questions coming in as as
our
our games uh we have fewer games we're
going to have a time to answer
more questions so it's kind of like at
the beginning of the broadcast
your questions can get in because the
games are just developing and at the end
of the broadcast
they are as well so we encourage you to
send your questions
comments at st louis chessclub.org or
using the hashtag
u.s chess champs and we have chess.com
goodies to give away
including diamond memberships exactly
and one question that came in recently
i noticed that gray of the higher rated
player in his game
so you might want to pull that game up
uh i have
oops yes the grave game yeah the higher
rate of player played the idiosyncratic
opening the hippo
do you think lower rated players should
avoid the idiosyncratic
a gm against a super gm for example
because the draw is more desirable
or should lower rated players risk the
element of surprise
just the same as higher rated players
well
first of all i think we should avoid
using the word idiosyncratic
for good reasons not to be a hater
you're right um
i'm i'm totally kidding about that but
i just think that in general
you shouldn't be thinking that much
about writing a lot of times as a coach
i noticed that people were really
obsessed with the rating of their
opponent
and they changed their strategy their
opening based on it
it's occasionally it makes sense but
usually it's a bad idea
right play the board not the rating and
play the opening that
best suits your style and if you see
your opponent
does poorly against a certain open by
all means use that as a reason to play
it
but don't use just the number as a
reason to justify
an opening choice or not exactly exactly
sometimes i fell into a trap when i was
growing up uh
in the northwest and i had become a very
strong
what we might call a senior master in
those days it was like
2400 and many my friends
were 2200 in the seattle portland
vancouver bc
area and i would play some
really really rotten openings
because i felt i had to take excessive
risks
and that was really silly of me i i
eventually uh
cured myself of that habit
well that was good how did you cure
yourself i stopped doing it
it sounds so easy you know so many
people could quit smoking
if they just use that advice ah good
point so easy
so easy just stop i quit doing it sugar
i need i need that advice with sugar
quit doing it okay so
uh in this game timor again uh
the clock's not as big a factor as the
other game
it looks 13 minutes to 10 minutes but
i'm just looking at the position and i'm
just
i don't see much in it for
either player at this moment of course
that doesn't mean
that they can't still keep fighting away
but it it does look pretty even
blitzing out i feel like that bishop is
not really on a square
which one the bishop that he just placed
on
f1 it feels like it's kind of like on a
half square
it's a little bit it's on f-zero okay uh
uh
a bishop too far huh we got another uh
just mentioned um
how chess makes you smarter great new
article in men health magazine
that quotes magnus carlsen and tony rich
the executive director here at the saint
louis chess club how did we do it
it's awesome so this article is all
about how chess can make you smarter
and it's in such a mainstream magazine
so it's very exciting
and they quote magnus carlsen is saying
training your brain is just as important
as training your body
it's like a muscle if you're not losing
it i'm sorry if you're not using it
you're losing
it right and there has been some recent
research that tries to suggest
you know that chess is a good antidote
against alzheimer's so it's not just
about kids
yes it's also about keeping the brain
active for adults did they also mention
you
me yeah they say that the best book for
beginners is play winning chess by
grand master yasser salon i'm shocked
i'm afraid that i've
ruined countless lives
with the books i've been writing but
really wow okay
and that was from what article i'm sorry
that's in men's health
so mental is the kind of magazine where
you see like six-pack after six-pack
like you know really buff arms and now
there's an article about chess in it as
well
so it's kind of fitting very good
fitting when you have a
also a world champion who's in such
fantastic shape and right you see
so many of the top 10 players are in
really good shape they're fit
yes absolutely so um
what else uh what big well we still got
verusion
going strong and the behind sky team
melakina game as well
maurice what do you think about that
anything new well
first of all maybe we should be showing
some buff arm chess players
yes i know uh you push do you do your
push-ups
especially after getting mated on the
back rank by the way
are you saying you're not getting mated
on the back rank often enough
uh i know i got mated on the back rank
before so i had to do a lot of push-ups
for that one
well just getting back to a serious game
this position
looks like it's completely turned around
and bygone skyte is no longer with any
advantage
whatsoever against bellahina so it looks
as though
she has to go on the defensive and her
clock situation is going to be
the main factor here because she's down
to one minute and 51
seconds and counting melojino with 12
minutes
plus and white has to figure out the
defense against the move bishop takes
on e3 she could try to trade queens here
but this is going to cost her
a piece after bishop to c3 it looks as
though this line is
maybe close to equal with the king being
the first thing
to run up the board but i don't want to
be black i don't want to be white here
for sure so the best defensive
maybe the most solid is this move and
after
bishop takes pawn takes queen check king
up to g2 and it looks like she did play
it which
took over the board from me let me just
get rid of uh
the receiving moves button there so if
bishop takes an e3 now
queen takes here it looks like she's
dead after d2 pawns about the queen
but oops checkmate back rank
check that out you don't want that to
happen in the game so
after king to g2 black would have to do
something about this move
and then the interesting defense queen
d1
and now king f1 and it looks
like she's hanging on by the skin of her
teeth
in this position so a tricky position
for white
after feeling like she was winning all
the way throughout now she has to find
proper defensive moves but again skyte
experienced the exact same thing
against the youngster in the competition
uh back uh
in was it round three so she doesn't
want this to happen to her
again losing a disastrous game after
having what looked like a decent
position so she seems i remember it was
with queens as well
in that one we saw four queens on the
board i don't think we're gonna see it
again four queens that would be pretty
crazy but certainly melakina seeming
like she's
back in business and in control of this
position back to you guys
quick question and we've got a we've got
a couple of buff arms to show off here
i think actually maurice is getting set
up for the next shot in which he's going
to take off his jacket
right and start lifting some weights on
the air
um that's what's up next for you guys
yeah puffed arms right
our massive female audience is now
getting really excited
they can get mad at me if i don't
deliver oh dear actually version
was featured on mtv true life a few
years ago and i think they showed him
going to the gym he is really fun
lifting yeah all right we do have some
moves let me just see
what has taken place in our key
games after
boy they're moving but i'm not getting
new new moves on my
ah i'm sorry
we'll have to go to maurice because i'm
not getting
the moves on my monitor so maurice if
you could show us
what has happened between jacobian
and ramirez yes it's actually a huge
development in that game guys ocobian
is now winning on the board after king
to d2
bishop to a4 was played rook to d6 and
now
rook takes e4 sacrificing an exchange
in order to achieve this position trying
to
fight back rook to h3 hitting a pawn and
king to g7
and now rook to e3 forcing a trade king
takes a rook takes king takes and
knocking back to f7
a great position for white the question
is can he convert
black has one in a pawn and a pawn for
the rook
and bishop so he's down in exchange but
he's hoping that this light square
blockade
will be too much for black
for white to be able to break through
this pawn is is defended by this knight
there's no way for this king to put any
more pressure on this this bishop
is invulnerable he can always go back
and forth
actually maybe winning is just much too
strong
a word here as i'm looking at it eugenie
likes the position
but i don't see how white wins this game
somehow getting the king in i mean look
at look at the wall
he's going to have to go through maybe
the king can get as far as here
but but how else to get in yaz i'm not
sure with your fine in-game technique
maybe you see a way
of making this position work i i
think white should have something but
it's really hard to see what that should
be
good point maurice um very important by
the way guys take a look at the clock
there
ocobia knows only 116. so he has a
technical
game ahead of him and with even with the
30-second increment on his clock
he's down to only 107 right now
he can actually make that up quite
easily by just playing a few bogus moves
which is uh unfortunately in my opinion
one of the minuses of the increment
he could just waste moves just to pad
his clock
right now that's probably what he's
going to do but he's going to have to do
it fast
and he's got to make use of the
advantage of being able to pad moves
46 seconds left that's a pretty crazy he
needs to make a move well he did play h4
and it was responded by a quick h6 by
ramirez
know that ramirez playing pretty quickly
i think he must assess that this
position is bad
and he wants to try to put pressure on
his opponent normally he wouldn't do
that
he would relax make the best moves but
here it might be his only shot
exactly exactly all right so
because i'm really watching please leave
like you like kobe makes a move ramirez
is like i'm ready
i'm ready bang it down because of course
if he thinks
even for 10 seconds ceremonially yeah if
he already has a move ready much better
to play it first
because that puts the pressure back in
var exactly as we call him for short
version we call him var
sure
he's got 34 seconds left he doesn't see
a win right but
he can just start moving pieces like why
not just move a piece
just to move it and then make like four
or five moves
my king would be dancing back and forth
in this position
king f2 king g3 king f3 king
e3 get a few minutes like right now he's
at
14 seconds 11
seconds 10 seconds nine so he got all
the way down to nine seconds and then he
made a move sometimes it's not so
easy to waste moves though remember like
you say it's oh it's so easy in uh
you know 30 second increment you know
give yourself a couple minutes and like
repeat the move twice but not three
times we already saw
an example of the hubris of that in this
tournament right as well run right
exactly that game should have been a
draw with a claim
but uh you know it's kind of hard to
keep track yeah
well i've actually been victimized
myself
and i've also benefited from my
opponent's time trouble
that they just as maurice said uh
they're dancing around
uh just trying to gain time on the clock
and i said okay three time repetition
whoops really
yeah but you're right maurice the the
the knight on d7 is a fabulous defender
of the
keep on the f6 pawn and the bishop
uh keeping a watchful eye
it's very hard to see how white's king
is going to do anything if it runs
over here to the king side didn't h4 and
h65 make the
the draw easier not harder i'm not sure
about each one
hard to say there jen on the one hand h4
when when var played the move h4
what he was hoping was
that he didn't want to see h7 h5 and see
his king get locked out
all right so he wanted an outpost on g4
first king
well he yeah he was thinking that okay
if i get in the move h4
h6 i do give myself the opportunity of
one day maybe trying to invade like this
the problem is
yes he has that opportunity but what
where is he going to go
the king just goes to h5 and in the
meanwhile black is moving as bishop
shuttling his bishop back and forth
between the b5
and the a4 squares or c6 squares
and i'm i'm having a real hard time
seeing how you think this is going to be
a draw
no it feels closer to it much much
closer
to a draw than it did earlier i was
always worried about these
exchange sacrifices i was always worried
that that that they might be sufficient
to hold
well romero ramirez playing very played
very well though to get these types of
chances you really held on in a position
that
was so dangerous but that's a problem
you have to take your beautiful position
and do something with it and you only
have
one option and it seems that he's
consolidated into something that
i hate to go back and be you know like
you know
in perfect hindsight and all the rest of
it but when we were back in a position
like this
i beg your pardon just back here i
thought that this was an ideal setup
for white that is to say the knight was
stuck on f6 and i really like that idea
of
whoa whoa i really like that idea of
rook d8
just trading rooks and getting ready to
post
the bishop on the c5 square we saw a
line like this and it just looked
ah horrible horrible scrumptious white
for sure no question about it and gives
no counter play to black
a horrible knight on f8 uh pieces are
just disjointed it was clear
that's what he should have done but but
also yes even in this moment
uh the moment when he got the chance to
play
keep going forward in this in this
position when he got the chance to play
rook to king over to g4
after this check he played his king back
so in this position he could have moved
this king over
a long time ago to get his king posted
on the h5 square that would have been
much nicer for him and now all his
pieces five of them
the two bishops the two rooks are in the
attack
and also his king and so everything
would have been here h4 would have come
in this moment
and black's position would just start to
burst at the seams so i think he played
passively
i think the main reason why he played
passively was because of the time
pressure
and now it really looks
like black has created a fortress yeah
it's true
too careful and uh yesterday we saw a
fortress created by anna zatonski who
was on the ropes
yeah that was really really lucky
because uh queen
uh if the queen had come to e1 at that
crucial moment it was victoria against
victoria yeah
yeah so yes you're right uh many
opportunities rook d8 opportunity king
h5
opportunity var perhaps a little too
careful
happy to win the exchange now looking i
believe very frustrated
uh to realize that um that was a
pretty good exchange sacrifice that he
forced his opponent
oh that will make alexander linderman
the clear leader despite
i'm losing today exactly it's pretty
incredible to lose your game and still
be in the clear lead
yeah now in bahrain skaiti milikina yeah
we've got a
an interesting little queen dance going
on okay let me bring the king had the
opportunity to make
three queens on the board what not three
just three total
not three of her own just three total
okay
so uh camilla doing her best to try to
create a perpetual exactly so what just
happened
was well let's just go back and show
when we had left it
uh uh there would have been a capture on
e4
and on e3 pardon me queen f2
there is this check made in one thread
that black has to deal with king g7 was
played
g4 queen e3
and what you're saying jen is the
immediate
uh promotion of the queen would allow a
perpetual check
that's right they can't escape the
checks they can't block them
because we have a nice dark square
control
whenever king h6 occurs we always have
queen h4
yeah it's a it's a real good pattern
that we should etch into our minds these
uh perpetual checks so when
when you know desperate desperation
calls you've got a
this perpetual checking a very important
tactical idea
absolutely it's not all about check
meeting sometimes you have to pursue the
draw
exactly and we've got uh maurice
ashley's got some thoughts on that
indeed camilla is going to kick herself
yet again because it looks like she is
completely
lost in this position it's just a
question of alyssa
finding the moves camilla remember she
lost the game against
the youngster in the competition ashrita
eswaran
also because of queens and here we go
again
in this position we saw that she could
have played the move
king to g2 this was an alternative for
her
and the point being that d2 was not
possible
because of the checkmate in one move
well
here after queen takes e3 check instead
she played the move queen to f2
offering a trade of queens which of
course would lose for black
but this move instantly loses this is
just a blunder the move queen c1
check king to g2 king to g7 in this
position
now houdini is going crazy guadini's
saying
that's a queen no matter what you do
after g4
d2 queen e3 white play
black played the correct move queen to
e1 and now
queen c3 check and she's praying for
some sort of
perpetual but it's not there the first
move to play is just simply king to h6
and what first of all there are no more
checks anywhere on the board
so the only move is this move check and
check this out
king of the board and now queen f3 check
give me that pawn and another check
there's plenty of checks of course to
calculate but it looks as though the
king is ready to march to the other side
now this is a long calculation
that the computer is looking at and
checking out all the variations
not easy for humans to just spot and
realize but we do know
that and she has played king 86 and g5
check
did indeed happen so all melakina has to
do is be
careful take everything that's given and
start marching that king
around to the other side the most
important thing though is that she has
five minutes on her clock so she has a
little bit of time to calculate
and camilla has only 147 but in this
position it's usually easier to play for
the person
trying to get the perpetual check
running because all you have to do all
you can do
is keep checking because this horsey
is looking to go home so she'll be
checking
as much as possible is white while
alyssa will be checking the variations
to see how she can get away from this
queen and
eventually win the game guys
thank you maurice a nice
a nice win
uh for melakina uh with this move king
h6 and king h5
and camilla is going to just hate queen
queen endings by the time this event is
over so that game looks to be heading
for victory for black
now uh we've got a for del gara still
going on you were predicting perhaps
a bishop of opposite ending at some
point and
instead we've got a night versus bishop
end game don't you like
josh ferdell's outfit there black and
white jacks
it looks really good right yeah it's a
great choice
true white or black they're good colors
right
well they're good colors aren't they
look at your white and black
we have the same outfit exactly
i am so fashion conscious obviously boy
okay
so let's see what is the memo yeah i
know i know somebody
please send me an email on this um so
what had happened
is we got our bishops of office of color
but
josh i think is saying with his
decision to capture he's saying well let
me see
let me explore this position a little uh
could white possibly win it
and now he's removing his night where
does he want that night to go the the
night looks pretty sweet over
on c5 but looks can sometimes be
deceiving because
it was adequately defended by the bishop
on e2
guarding a6 completely solidly right so
now he's headed for
another square maybe he wants to play 93
and then
you think he's going towards f4 right he
he wants to provoke
black into playing the move um
g6 g5 so for example let me just put
some bad moves on the position so i do
apologize i'm not
playing well for t margarita but i just
would like to show
how josh is trying to imbalance the
position for a second so
something like g5 here and now he needs
to
well if i take take e5 check no
that doesn't i would like to
i would like to isolate these pawns some
more
so that i can move i can do a whole new
series of maneuvers and get my knight to
a nice square and one day one day
play for king c5 so chances for
josh and he's right to exp explore them
yeah we love to see them try to squeeze
these out so
what about the idea of playing knight e3
and then they did c4 check and perhaps
get the king to c5
that would be a nice one too i if i gave
black the opera
if i gave white the opportunity to try
to do that oops
we have to assess the pawning game but
you mean it looks like my white pawns
are
quite quite well advanced here so
you think this king and pawn end game
you need to take a look at that oh
because you're just gonna
i don't know what i'm just going to do
it might be good it might be bad
well the problem you know we have to
count the tempos here right right
g4 king here g5
um how fast am i it may not be that fast
actually
but maybe i don't have to do anything
either i can just wait
well if you can just wait that's a
problem yeah i think i could just wait
because then you you don't even have to
bother calculating you can wait until
right so calculate king e5 but if this
is sufficient then why should white go
for it
exactly exactly but uh
all right well i mean it's an
interesting game for sure maurice what
uh what about your insights on this one
well we've been referencing another game
quite a bit that is
going to haunt camilla began skyte for a
long time to come
except you know she might have thought i
got rid of those queen issues
it's dead i got it and now all of a
sudden it's another queen ending
and we're talking about this game i
shriek i swear on
with the white pieces against camilla
bug and skyte and in this position
with one step away from queening
bhaginskaite
played the move e3 check king g2 king g3
e2 and now h8 queen
and we saw the infamous four queens on
the board
usually a win for the side with the
queens
but in this position right here black
was perfectly fine
no worries whatsoever until after queen
b3 check
she completely missed the move queen to
e3 which would not only have saved the
game but given her
an advantage instead she played the
immediate blunder king to d4
and this queen trade sealed her fate in
order
to stay on this pawn she would have to
play king takes but if she had done that
she would have lost her queen to the
skewer
instantly so instead she did play in
time pressure
after queen takes e4 she did capture
with her queen but then she lost her
pawn and also
queen trade is happening anyway and this
pawn and this pawn being too
far apart too stretched cost her the
game she had to resign
in this moment now she's in this
position on the board trying
the same thing to fight back with a
queen this time she's on the white side
she's trying to chase this king around
if this king ever finds any haven
somewhere
in the position over here the game is
over but there's a long way to go
and a lot of maneuvers that melahina
will have to do to not get caught
by a perpetual check and both sides down
to two
minutes and four seconds for camilla uh
against kaita who has white
and alyssa malachina has 339 and she's
bringing her king over trying to avoid
those checks so we'll keep a close eye
on this to see if belakina can figure it
out and win the game
guys yeah three very intense end games
that we have going on still
very tight games uh varushana colombian
against ramirez looks like it's
simplified further
has it so they've played some glorious
moves
before i go to that game the the josh
riedel has won upon
but it may have been a mistake
for him to win the pawn i this is a
really
really strange uh minor piece ending
in minor piece endings with pawns on
both flanks
normally speaking the bishop is better
but in this case obviously white's a
pawn up
but on the other hand black has ideas of
his own
playing king d4 king e3 to win his pawn
back
also he has ideas like g5 g4
so that once he does win the pawn he can
bring his pawn to f4 as well
this is wild i my judgment
is i don't know
what's going on in this game you you
want to say that white's better because
he's a pawn up
but that could be completely wrong
it's going to take just cold
calculation to determine who stands
better
but i wouldn't be surprised if black
is good in this game it's just
a very unusual energy we did play uh the
moves king c5 and g4 have appeared on
the
board and of course uh players are going
to be in some amount of time pressure
five minutes each
maurice if i can get you to tell me
what the computer how the computer
assesses this one
uh does black have sufficient
compensation for a pawn
is white even better at all yes your
instincts were dead on as a matter of
fact
scary dead on the key move here was king
to d4
he should have played this first before
the move g5 actually that king
was the power move you were talking
about having a king on that square gives
lots of chances but by playing the move
g5
first white goes back in the driver's
seat by playing king c5
keeping the king out of the position not
that it's so easy to win though but the
move g4
the computer says what is that it
doesn't like it at all
what's the move this beautiful move
knight back
to b1 preventing this pawn from being
captured
right now and if obviously if king takes
then simply knight check
the king goes in give us that piece and
then b5
and white is going to queen upon quickly
and win this game
we presume he'll win the game because it
looks like there's too much action over
here
on this side once this queen appears on
the board
after knight b1 how does black stop the
simple maneuver
knight to c3 followed by b5 anyway this
position looks
totally lost now for black he had one
moment
to play instead of instead of g5 to play
king d4 but by waiting a tempo and
putting white's king
on the c5 square it looks as though
black is completely lost
and will go down a second game in a row
in these championships
wow it looks like friedel did find the
move knight to b1
it's on the board now and graeve is
trying to figure out what to do
but i think he realizes the danger here
that he's in a world of hurt
and doesn't know what to do next and you
see his hand
hovered for a moment and then he's back
to thinking and he's probably inside
thinking
oh boy he looks like he's turning
bright red why i don't like that
oh my god what a swing because king d4
just i didn't know how to assess the
position after king d4 i
thought that black was getting really
great play actually
and this move knight b1
that's a simple move truthfully because
king takes e4 just walks into this fork
easy winning king upon end game
if black tries to just wait it out
well guess what this a5 pawn is going to
decide the game
um do we play a6 immediately i suppose
we do
right well this round is all about
players who are at minus one i'm
climbing back up to even right
josh wins this game he'll join ray
robson and sam shankland
as players who started the day with two
points and now have an even score within
striking distance of the tournament
leader
wow wow by the way we should mention
that grave
might be getting some comeuppance
remember in the first round how he threw
away his white
by taking a quick draw you know that's a
sign to me when you
play a tournament that in your very
first round instead of thinking you know
this could be the time i put my hammer
on this guy right here and show what i'm
about you play kg you play a 14 move
draw
that shows a lack of confidence uh not
not the guy who you think
is going to be the eventual champion of
the event
with the white pieces and now he's
actually taking the pawn on e4
but what's that there's no chance it
looks like there and fridael has just
jumped on it
with the move knight to c3 and it could
be that grave is going to lose two games
in a row
if that happens his chances of winning
this championship have been severely
compromised i don't see it happening at
all with all those uh
other players leading in the in the
tournament right now of course
anything can happen with five rounds to
go but this will be rough to come back
from
wow i just see no chances uh
king takes e4 that's lost i mean yes
it's over
that's a time pressure move i'm
wondering uh what is the clock situation
looks like actually he didn't have he
had enough time time to look at it but
you know you so that you're just looking
at your doom it's
probably not cool just to sit there but
what other chances did he have his
bishop was this awful
wow so a real surprise for me i thought
that this game was
heading for a draw for a long long long
time
and team or stumbling
back-to-back games actually wow right
and kudos to josh riddell our u.s open
champion
who deserving qualifier winning winning
one of the strongest open
uh events held in the united states it
was held in madison and this year's
edition was originally going to be held
in st louis but unfortunately
the hotel it was booked for closed door
hate that
that was the and so instead it's moved
to florida but it's going to be back in
st louis in a couple years
let's hope so so josh uh king f3 was
played as expected and josh
quickly snapped out knight takes e2 and
i just don't i can't imagine timor
continuing the game
um for too long oh i looked at it
of course he's completely losing but i
think his only chance and i was
wondering what he was thinking about
trying to get inside his head
right here there's a chance that he can
gobble up all the paws on the king side
that's probably what he's after if we go
to the moment after king takes e2
b5 a takes b5 a6
i mean this is hopeless it's got to be
hopeless a7 king takes g3 a8 queen
and then king takes h4 and then he could
pray that somehow there's a draw
in this position unfortunately houdini
is saying that it's made in nine
but but he can maybe hope that somehow
he can
he can get out of this one the problem
is that this king could come back and
king and queen together are just going
to make it hopeless
uh but i'm wondering that's probably
what he's thinking in a blitz situation
you hope and pray that somehow you could
get a george position it looks like
he is indeed going exactly for that line
trying to make some trouble for friedel
but
i think josh is thinking um i don't
think so i'm just going to queen my pawn
and there he goes bam the queen has
arrived on the board
and now a question of taking the pawn or
moving the king
forward both should somehow lose his
only hope may be that g-pawn so that's
probably why he's stopping right now yes
thinking that maybe he he could move his
king and push the g-pawn somehow
and make it into somebody but seems like
it's just
hopeless exactly we were about to find
out why
the queen is the strongest piece on the
board and even three connected past
pawns
are not going to stop white's victory um
i like your move king d4 very much
simply king d4 king
e3 looks like simplest to me
in a blitz game i probably bang down
queen g2
just to make sure the pawns aren't going
anywhere as well to keep the king from
coming to g3
exactly coming down um we got one uh
comment actually question from u.s chess
champs as we see all these close-ups of
the players in the webcam
our friend baron from italy i believe he
asked
do you know what the design of the
pieces they're playing with
it's a very detailed nights and thin and
elegant tall pieces well
actually the pieces are created by one
of our sponsors house of staunton it's a
special edition chess set
made just for this event so we love that
you noticed that
and welcome to the show really a shout
out to frank camarata i think one of the
greatest
chess set designers ever full stop uh
his creations are fantastic and
these are very special heavily weighted
pieces
that actually work with the dg board so
you don't have to play with those lousy
um chess sets you see at olympiads and
other events
but these are like the finest staunton
designed chess sets
and uh the house of staunton makes the
best chess sets in the world it's just
great
and they're we're so happy to have uh
the
sponsor by the way frank was here
earlier uh
before the tournament was staged
because he had to test all the equipment
and make sure all of the pawns and
pieces work with the dgt boards maurice
you have a thought well it turns out
that camilla began skyte with her
unlucky game
against eswaran is now extremely lucky
in this one and seems like she has found
her way to perpetual check
and will draw this game in this moment
in the game she played the move
queen to f3 check she's just lost
let me tell you she's just lost here
what that
what it took though to win was very
subtle maneuvers
king to c7 was the right move in this
position
that would have kept the win going and
after queen to
f7 check king to d6 she's well on her
way
to victory but actually no this is the
way she played my apologies
the way she actually played the move
here that she should have played was
king d5
and after king queen c4 she could
maneuver this king around
so that the perpetual check doesn't
continue hard lines to see
this triangulation of the king around
this pawn but instead she
still was winning here but when this
move king d6 was played
queen for check she played king e7 and
tried to run back to this side of the
board
this is not going to work queen c7 check
the computer is now saying
perpetual check is on the board queen c6
check
king over and as he tries to hide back
on the other side
queen d6 check king g7 queen c7 check
and now she can't go up the board
because there's too many check the
checks are just continuing and the queen
can't come
back to help at any point because this
queen will always snap this pawn off so
it looks like she has chances to save
the draw
that doesn't mean anything by the way
we're just saying chances
are on the board now it looks like
malachina has blown
the victory but with the time pressure
anything could happen
wow that's uh
that's a surprising uh turn of events
because it just seemed that malikina all
she needed to do was to play a few
accurate moves to get out of those
perpetual checkmate
checking patterns and uh she came up
with the wrong
plan realizing that
it does look like a perpetual check in
the position she she can feel like a
victory
in your hands that really hurts oh oh
dell has won his game against graham it
looks like that game is finished
aha timor didn't even go for the h4 pawn
which
made it very easy in that case so no
doubt josh riddell feeling awesome
winning this key game and getting his
score back up to even at the usgs
championships
um i'm sure we'll hear from him in just
a bit but
what about varus nakobian and alejandra
ramirez
now we see that the only way for
a colby to really get anything in this
position is if you can somehow attack
the f6 pawn twice is that going to be
possible
thrice oh twice he's somehow
wow okay uh
i'm am i surprised he was able to make
this much progress and
i'm a little surprised yeah but it is
but this is so this is interesting so
now he's just played this
to go to the current position now the
times are a lot more equal version of
copying with about two minutes
ramirez was over five but um before
remember it was 16-1 or something
right so things are equally using a bit
in that department and you're bringing
us back a few moves
yeah i'm just i'm just shocked that uh
i don't think that ramirez defended this
very well
i'm just shocked that he took this
bishop but all right let's just get to
the
to the game position and now um okobian
needing to reroute his rook because of
course
wasn't doing much on b6 right and now
he's
so his rook is active
and well i mean white has a very
clean pathway to go after this f6 pawn
that's right we want to get that to g6
and then
you'd have to defend it with the king
somehow but with the rook
sitting here on the seventh rank that
looks very hard
if you go if uh ramirez goes after the
c5 pawn the problem is
is when the f6 pawn falls so does the g5
pawn
and that f pawn is a bonner that one's
ready to go
right but hold on i
seriously i don't either i think that
this must be lost yes i don't even want
to look at it
i was preparing to give up the bishop
for the f pawn and try to get some
pounds
but no uh and if if ramirez
drops back with us but this has happened
on the board what has happened on the
board
can you see 85 has been traded for f6 oh
boy
bad news for ramirez so
uh okay let me take that back i
apologize so king c6 was played
rook h6 was played king c5 rook f6
you're saying it looks like
he wasn't going to be able to hold on to
it that's a problem yeah it just seems
that way
and now king b5 has been played so okay
so
i didn't want to look at this but but
now we have
now i have to i i was going to say i
didn't see an
another chance for ramirez i didn't see
another line of play i'm looking at
the move rook d6 now six was played and
now bishop to a2 was quickly
because the problem is the bishop
doesn't have a good square it has to
keep contact with this pawn on f5
but once you move your bishop for
example bishop to a2 there's this rook
b6 and rook takes b7
and because your king is caught on the a
file i think white's king is going to be
very fast here let me just right by
contrast between going
f6 and at least letting you get the two
pawns right
so something like this i don't know
shouldn't i just be winning here
easily um
just putting out some i
think i i think i'm in time i think i'm
winning with white
grandmaster josh ferdell looking at you
quizzically so maybe he helps him
answers
and uh he's with maurice um they're both
making faces
okay let's go to them they can make all
the faces they want maurice ashley with
josh ferdau who's
now on an even score after a nice
victory today
against one of the pre-tournament
favorites exactly indeed
even seems to be the popular place to be
where all the kids are hanging out
josh welcome to the show thank you uh so
the game was weird i mean he played this
hippopotamus line
nothing was exchanged for quite some
time how did you finally break through
uh well it was you know with timor it's
never simple
um so i expected him to do like in the
past he's actually played very solidly
against me we had you know interesting
games but
he wasn't able to do much so i think he
tried to surprise me and play
just something but it was a very strange
position because it looks like a very
nice hippo for white because he can't
castle his king
but the problem is i have this clump of
pieces in the middle of the board and i
found it really difficult to untangle
but the nice thing is that he can
basically do nothing without getting
checkmated
so i can play like these ridiculously
looking slow moves
and eventually i was able to untangle a
bit and
um but at some point i think i gave up a
large portion of my advantage because in
the end game
i thought i had chances but i didn't
think i should be able to win yeah it
looked like it was going to be a draw
for some time then all of a sudden
it's like whoa what happened here yeah i
blundered this move um
when we i played c4 i thought i had a
huge advantage but i blundered this move
bishop c6
that he played after rook t1 show us
that position what number was it
all right where is it was it in the
first time control
uh yeah so you can just hit the the side
to make that contact all right so let's
see
it was about move 28
to move 30. it's around here ah yeah
there we go
so i had this position and i thought
that this was nice for me uh
my plan was rook d1 which is what i
played but i missed this move bishop c6
which apparently is terrible
but uh see i thought rookie 8 i could
play rook d7 and my position was quite
nice but
uh apparently it's nothing special so
yeah i mean i probably overestimated my
position i thought his bishop on b7 was
bad he had weaknesses his pieces on the
king's side are
less than ideal let's say but uh i guess
he can untangle but after bishop c6 i
missed this move and i thought it was
pretty good
but apparently i can play knight d3 but
okay i mean i didn't see any of this uh
we were just finishing up time control
so
i decided to trade into this end game
which i thought was okay close to equal
but i thought that only i had chances
um which is always a nice place yeah on
the plus side of equal yeah
because to go from like some huge
looking position to losing is is very
depressing so i figured at least here
okay i'd test him a bit and see if he
defended well and i don't know i thought
that it should have been
a draw for a while and then when i had
knight against bishop i thought it was
promising but it was hard to calculate
all the variations where i try to go
after his queen side he goes after my
king's side with no time
um but in the end i think he just
blundered uh
let me see if i can find this position
ah
yeah he had d king d4 instead of g5 yes
that's what i ex that's what i spent all
my time calculating actually
uh so king takes c6 yeah here i spent
all my time calculating team d4
i planned knight b3 check and i i had
all this analysis which i wasn't sure of
i didn't know if i was winning
losing drawing or some other result uh
but he played g5 which was very
surprising to me and then after king c5
he played g4 and i i figured he
overlooked this knight b1 move which was
one of the ideas i had in another
variation so it was easy for me to find
uh and after that i think it's just
losing yeah wow
great win i mean it must feel really
good right now it's nice to know i can
win a chess game
so that much that much is very positive
so i think that
uh you know it wasn't the cleanest game
but at the same time i never felt like i
was worse or anything like that so
um you know pretty happy with the game
and that i was able to win somehow
so who do you have tomorrow i get black
against alejandro ramirez i think
okay so still work to be done but
congratulations on your win and best of
luck in the rest of the tournament thank
you
grand master josh friedel coming off a
nice win tough struggle
against the number two ranked player in
the tournament back to you guys
well i was checking out how you avoid
getting killed by a hippopotamus
of course grandmaster joshua dell is the
expert on this but apparently
you should not try to fight you should
always try to run because
you'll never want to fight but they
don't run that fast so if you run fast
you might be able to escape
so good practical knowledge for all of
you guys listening
if you have a choice between fight or
flee always flee
right get the head ball and try to climb
a tree i would i mean hippos are real
fast for the first 100 meters by the way
well they get tired easily though
well that's what i'm saying they cannot
go about 100 meters at good speed
but if they hit you it's like a 5 000
pound battering
we've got another decisive raw result
alejandra ramirez has resigned against
the kobe and
as we thought that f pawn is too strong
he's not going to be able to deal with
it just with the a
pawn and ferrun okobian the tournament
leader now
along with lenderman right love to see
this guy he's
really a st louis guy st louis grand
master in residence
that's right he comes here every single
classic chess club and he does videos
he's a
very popular coach so i'm sure a lot of
his students are rooting him on and
i think we'll get a chance to uh hear
from him soon um st
louis it's been a good day for them
right uh ray robbins
winning we actually had a grandmaster
susan pogar listening to our broadcast
and she said that
she's also listening to bohomian
rhapsody
by queen of healing and rhapsody so
that's nice uh
we've got a lot of stars watching our
broadcast
you know i actually saw some of the
students from webster and you see the
students from linden were kind of
coming to the club and coming to the
museum for all the events it's
it's really a great chess culture that
yes not just when the championships are
taking place
but anytime you come here exactly
you see at least three grandmasters over
at starbucks
i still like this uh uh susan and i had
gone
for coffee close by and the webster team
had gone out to lunch so we're
chit-chatting and as we
get out of the coffee shop she sees her
son tom
hey tom so tom joins us and the next
thing you know
the entire webster team joins us so the
whole group of us are walking down
and you know 100 yards into the walk tom
his son says hey i'm the only
person here who's not a grand master
that's really hilarious that's how you
feel like when you're in st
louis huh exactly the town of grand
masters you gotta solve a rook engine
before they let you off the plane
you bet and uh yeah i'm pretty thrilled
by this uh
excitement that we've got in the
championship two leaders in the u.s
championship
we've got a cobian and we've got
lenderman and then in the women's
championship of course we have zatonski
and crash
right plenty of players in the
championship particularly within
striking distance
right we know that lenderman's got a
tough task with two
facing two back-to-back blacks against
the two favorites in the
in the field and we'll ha and i think
actually var
has played a few of the very strong
players as well so maybe var is
uh in pole position here
yeah that's a really good point maurice
your thoughts
if you could
well indeed it looks as though he was
drawing
and drawing and drawing and now we've
awoken
the hippopotamus he's up he's starting
to hit hard
and he's won two games in a row clearly
uh the first game he defeated the number
two player in the tournament
now he's defeated last year's runner-up
so verounkovian who has
never won the title here is definitely
making a run
here in round six now tied with
alexander
lenderman so he looks like he's in
really fine form it's nice
to be solid and then win it means that
you're not
uh you're not shaky although the reality
is he had
other opportunities he could be the one
running away with this tournament
as a matter of fact because he missed
some chances earlier in the tournament
linderman on the other hand that loss
although he's tied for first
that loss today he's even in great
spirits he's going to have to
really bring his a game tomorrow against
kamsky and then he's got onus chuck
behind that
and with the black pieces two times in a
row and these guys are nipping at his
heels
nipping at a cobian's heels so i think
that's going to be a really
tough battle for him uh he's going to
really have to show it
despite the fact that he's been playing
well so far in the tournament it's
really easy i've seen lindemann tip over
and then
keep tipping over when it happens so
he's not the kind of guy who normally
loses and then bounces right back with
a guaranteed victory so they smell blood
with him but varus nakobian boy he's
looking really strong
right now tomorrow he's going to play
against grandmaster ray robson
and we are also going to have a big
matchup with correa playing against
onoshuk
camp skiing as slenderman and uh yeah
we're really going to be in for some
thrillers tomorrow
big battles on those boards and for the
ladies
well in the ladies tomorrow we see irena
crush playing against
alyssa milikina who is going to draw
today
yeah that's right and honestly playing
against her friend camilla bahan skyty
which she mentioned and very
respectfully
and those will be the two big battles
because right now those are the ones to
watch right they're
both ahead of the field tatev abrahamian
playing against being a foister so
plays you know aggressively and strings
together a couple wins she'll be a
threat as well
exactly and we have verounkovia now
tied for the lead and the u.s chess
championship a big surprise for us
earlier in the tournament
because he started with all drawls right
indeed a new co-leader has emerged
verouncobian first of all welcome to the
show and congratulations on your victory
thank you
did you think you were winning all the
way through uh you seem to have a nice
opening
set up but then it seemed to have
slipped back a little bit you had to
like
restart the car yeah i agree absolutely
i had a very big advantage in the
opening i think alejandro did something
wrong probably c5
and i had a big advantage there but i
didn't play the best way i
spent a lot of time actually about half
an hour to try to find a
clean way to pursue it but i didn't see
anything and then i went for it
i always had a slight advantage and i
think that i played well in the end game
if when i played f4 and i was always
better i think
indeed and you played this move f5 which
was a really nice move counter-intuitive
because you
allowed the backward pawn but i was
remembering a game with lasker uh way
back in rural lopez days
playing this move f5 and and also bobby
fischer got the same kind of idea
to play as well yeah in this type of end
games when you have two bishops actually
space is very important so when i played
f5 i actually restrict the knight on f8
and now black is actually running out of
moves and then i can put the king on f4
which i did
i just i wish i would have played h4
first to stop the g5 counter play then i
think i would have probably won
easier did you miss this movie i missed
g5 i forgot that when i take
fg egos knight g6 i thought i can take
kuruk g6 but i forgot that
i'm no longer attacking that bishop on
b3 in other variations i could do that
but
but i think even though after g5
it still should be winning did you feel
like it was going to be an easy win
when you were up in exchange like that
it was just over or did did you think he
may have had some chances with the
blockade
uh well i didn't have that much time to
actually think about the result i just
you know i saw this idea
i think very important move in the end
game was h4
to exchange the pawn so i can have this
entry point with the king on h5 because
otherwise he plays h5
and whenever i play h4 he will close the
king's eye with g4
so h4 was very important to exchange and
then i saw this plan that
i exchanged the bishop for knight and
then he's basically he cannot do much
i bring my king on g4 and at the end
when i played rook c8
this is a key move show us that position
so here i played so
so first first i played rook h3 here so
now threatening rook h7 check so he has
to go king g7 because otherwise if the
king is caught up on the back rank
then i simply put the rook on c7 and
then i have an entry point with king h5
king that's why h4 earlier was important
so i played kg7 now i could rook d3
now i can enter today the eighth rank
king f7 rook d8
kings 7 and rook c8 king h7 i saw the
rook h8 idea but i just rip it one time
because he cannot do anything and then
rook c8
i need the king on d7 here it's very
important because
if i go to kh8 immediately as bishop d5
and check he has bishop f7 and my king
cannot enter so that's why rook
rook king d7 and then rook has so no
longer he can play bishop f7 now so this
is already lost because
now i check and uh simply and then
as soon as i win the pawn on f6 then i
win the king is actually well placed
and just the final idea here uh final i
think
important move is rook d6 here forcing
the bishop away from the diagonal so i
can
check check and win the pawn on b7 and
here
you should be careful not to try to
promote the f-pawn
it's because then he can try to make a
draw with the steel mate i guess so
that's why i just need to bring my king
to the king side first because then i
can promote your pawn
very fine in-game technique you showed
here you're tied for first in the u.s
championship
how does it feel yeah i don't even know
i was just playing my game so i didn't
watch a lot of others well lenderman
lenderman lost his game
so he came back and calmskin ownership
drew gorey have lost his game
so you're tied for first uh on plus two
after six rounds have you ever been in
this position before yeah i was actually
leading in the 2009 championship also
yeah so so what do you need to do to
keep it going keep the momentum going
i just need to just continue play well
i'm happy the way i played
yesterday after that mistaken opening
but i think
overall i played a good game today just
need to just play well
one game at the time one game at a time
we know it's hard who do you play
tomorrow
i think i'm playing great robson
tomorrow ray robson he won his game
today what kind of battle do you think
that'll be i think it will be exciting
game because ray
plays very active and i've played it
many times so it should be very
interesting
you'll have the black pieces against him
i assume uh what openings normally
come out of that we played many games we
had a lot of
french defense battles when ray was very
young but
now he's much stronger so then we had
some karo khan
so we had karo khan lately last couple
of times and some french defenses
you're at four and uh lenderman's at at
four as well but you got two guys behind
you komski and honest truck who
they know how to win and and they're
chasing you right now what is it like
when you're the leader and being chased
by
strong players like that um i'm not sure
i haven't been a leader that much in
this tournament so it's uh to be honest
hard to say but i'm not too worried
about the lead or anything it's just
we're at the halfway
halfway mark so we played six rounds we
have five more to go and
all the games are going to be very tough
and just need to try to prepare well
and play well well congratulations and
you win today and we wish you the best
in the rest of the tournament
grand master of version of cobian tie
for first
nice place to be back to you guys
very nice place to be all right uh
varushana colby and alexander lenderman
not exactly what people would have
expected at this point in the
championship
yeah well at the halfway point uh still
a big
feeling out process and i'm
i'm more than surprised by um
timor's uh back-to-back losses i just
didn't see that one coming either that's
right well back-to-back losses for timor
and back-to-back wins for verizon
columbia let's take a look at the
standings
we got lenderman and ukobian in the lead
with four points kamsky and ownership
just a half a point behind it don't
remember don't forget that we've got
kamsky and lenderman facing off tomorrow
so
this could be big for kamsky he says
that he thinks this is the year
that somebody is going to dethrone him
but when he plays
he's not going to be bringing that
attitude to the board that's only a
post-game interview attitude
um and now in the women's championship
of course we have
our perennial favorites idrina crush and
anna zadowski both a point ahead of the
field
um tata vapor homie and trailing by a
point but with the type of aggressive
play
chess that she showed today who knows
what will happen you're gonna have to
join us
we will be here again tomorrow at 1 pm
central standard time
and i'm signing off jennifer shahadi for
grand masters yasser sarwan and maurice
ashley we will see you tomorrow for some
more thrilling chess in the capital of
chess
in america saint louis
you